yeah just stop waving it around it ain't
funny Red Dead Redemption is a harsh
world it's filled with dangerous
criminals ready to draw on you at a
moment's notice
rough and ready characters with dark
pasts and desperate futures as well as
wildlife that will soon a death roll you
than become your new 10 cover there's
been plenty of discussion around the
story of Red Dead Redemption - its
characters its quests and its plethora
of mechanics but I want to talk about
how Red Dead 2 can actually be a
relaxing game if you'd give it a chance
to be so far all the quests have
experienced be they from the main story
or side missions from strangers have
been gripping action-packed and
thoroughly enjoyable Affairs so much so
that I can understand why players would
want to - from one to another as soon as
they're available but Red Dead
Redemption - also has so much to give
the am blurs among us those willing to
let the interesting moments come to them
instead there's a certain enjoyable
simplicity in doing pretty much nothing
Rockstar have nailed that sensation of
escapism and an almost zen-like peace
that few other games have mastered the
enjoyment of wandering off the beaten
track having a moment of calm to take in
each element of the beautifully crafted
world is that complete odds with the
route in - in revolver shooting that
drives the game's main narrative forward
but it's also become one of my favorite
things to do in Red Dead almost like a
palate cleanser after a heist or a train
robbery I found myself disappearing into
mountains of forests not to just escape
Johnny Lomond but because they're
wonderful places to be the serene and
picturesque portions of the world
offered valuable moments of calm in a
world that is otherwise in upheaval
moments where I could imagine
Arthur forgetting about his dubious
moral choices of holding up a store on a
Monday but being the noble outlaw and
charity Giver on a Wednesday going for a
long fishing trip or a huge hunting
session reminds me strangely of how Euro
Truck Simulator 2 used to relax me or
how in GTA 5 I'd often find it quite
calming to spend a while driving through
the city obeying traffic laws and
respecting bystanders
as I discovered more of the world I
found myself spending more time taking
in the amazing views from a mountain
peak appreciate an e response or
watching people go by in towns the
cities you can almost become kind of a
virtual voyeur watching life happen
around you so dense is the detail that
it could be easy to forget that it
exists as ones and zeros lines of code
and pixels think about the term people
watching where individuals will detach
from the inward focus that we all
generally have and focus more on what's
around them that gives you a weirdly
comforting reminder that the world
doesn't revolve around you and Rockstar
have recreated that sensation in a
virtual sense whether or not Arthur or
the player is there to see it this small
part of America is living and breathing
and developing without his direct
influence this method of experience the
world of Red Dead Redemption too has
also resulted in some of the more
fascinating moments sure we can all
share about when Arthur gets absolutely
shit-faced on whisky with Lenny and all
had a great time but taking the path
less trodden has gifted me some rarer
moments after taking a walk down a river
I found a gold prospector and sure it
might have been a little creepy watching
him through binoculars but it genuinely
made me smile when I saw him discover a
nugget of gold and gallop away and then
tried to resist the temptation to gun
him down and take the Nugget for myself
taking the time to appreciate the world
really allow the environmental
storytelling to shine through wonderful
little scenes to appreciate your own
pace or actions happening organically
without Arthur's influence I saw some
real nature be crazy [ __ ] when I saw a
bear defending its kill from some wolves
and a frozen Lagoon or happening a pie a
shack containing two corpses murder
weapons and a gold nugget the scene of
two apparent business partners fighting
for their find or even in a more
wholesome moment a young man stressing
over his love while skipping stones into
a lake talking himself through some
heavy things
begging me to court you it's those sort
of fines that I can tell other players
about things that have made friends or
colleagues want to go for a little
nomadic trip of their own of course this
has all helped along by the fact the
game is bloody gorgeous seeing light
burst through a tree canopy rain clouds
forming and clearing before my eyes and
evening mist rolling into an eerie swamp
and snow and mud move before my forward
stride was a joy to see each environment
feels varied and unique from the
landscape to the color palette from the
terrain even down to the people you see
I felt a pull to see it all and that
urge I had was being rewarded with
interesting moments that really stuck
with me I wanted to see what was over
that next rise what was on top of each
Hill what was hidden alleyways I
wondered past and cinematic mode even
took what could have been a chore of a
long ride to a slideshow of landscapes
that was different with each journey it
disconnects you from your first person
or third person point of view and
seamlessly presents the wider world
around you taking you out of that
autopilot canter for word instead of
taking a stagecoach or a train I would
let the ride play out either enjoying a
podcast or a conversation during the
journey or just letting the wonderful
music score develop with the trip all
that being said though it's not without
its hiccups so make sure you use
cinematic camera responsibly
I wanted to make you watching this a
hone thing about how you're experiencing
the game now you've bought the game
you've shed out the cash for it if you
want to - to each story mission that's
your call and I can totally respect that
but I wanted to make a case for slowing
down a little bit because there really
is some cool stuff to see while many
games offer hectic moments of moment
gameplay it's felt so refreshing the Red
Dead Redemption - does such a good job
its subtly rewarding players for taking
a slower pace so if you want to take my
advice I'd advise taking your foot off
the gas or your stirrups out of the
horses hip and just go for a wander if
you don't find something cool then I
will eat my 10 gallon hat Red Dead
Redemption - feels very much like a slow
burner that many of us will be enjoying
for a while but I'd be interested to
hear about how you've been taking in
rock stars mammoth world so please share
your thoughts in the comment section
below or you can find me on twitter at a
regular Dave I hope you enjoyed the
video make sure to clean your guns be
nice to your horse and I'll see you in
the next one
[Music]